as expected the cincinnati bengals made
lsu quarterback joe burrow the number
one overall pick in the 2020 draft there
was an effort by the dolphins to make
the move from number five to number one
we don't yet know what if anything
concrete was offered there were various
ideas that were percolating out there
the question of whether or not the
dolphins could offer cash to the bengals
and we know how extremely careful the
bengals are with money and how they
value money but there is a long-standing
nfl policy that for player drafts
or for player trades rather money cannot
be part of the equation i actually heard
that there was a thought that maybe the
dolphins could take the fifth overall
pick pay his signing bonus and then
trade into the dolphins or to the
bengals rather with the signing bonus
already paid by the dolphins and then
pick up joe burrows contract and pay his
signing bonus in full contract that
gives you an idea of the kind of
creativity and outside the box thinking
that was going on this wasn't some
idle
issue by the dolphins where they just
kicked the tires and maybe thought about
trying to do it they wanted to do it the
bengals said no and maybe one of these
days we'll find out exactly what the
dolphins offered to get joe burrow but
for the bengals who kept joe burrow he
becomes the future what will he do with
andy dalton will joe burroughs start
right away can they put enough around
him to turn the bengals into a contender
they haven't won a playoff game since
january of 1991 and now with joe burrow
it's a new era for the bengals and we'll
see if they can turn things around in
cincinnati we'll be back all night long
with more reaction to picks made during
the 2020 nfl draft
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports